هشام زقوت في رفح حاليا وينضم الينا من
جديد اهلا هشام من جديد يعني ضعنا في صوره
اي معلومه جديده او اي مستجد يمكن ان
تضيفه
تفضل ليلى القصف المدفعي حتى الان هو سيد
الموقف في خانيونس الاوضاع تشتد والقصف
يشتد واطلاق النار ايضا يشتد 28 شهيدا
وصلوا الى مستشفى ناصر من جراء استمرار
اطلاق النار والقصف المدفعي في مناطق
مختلفه وجل هذا القصف المدفعي او ابرزه في
منطقه حي الامل ومحيط مستشفى ناصر حتى
الان الاصابات هذه الشهداء والاصابات التي
وصلت الى مستشفى ناصر هذا ما استطاعت
سيارات الاسعاف الوصول اليه في محيط في
المحيط القريب جدا من مستشفى ناصر لان
عمليات اطلاق النار مستمره ومتواصله حتى
على سيارات الاسعاف التي تمنعها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من الدخول الى
المناطق التي تقصف فيها التي تطلق النيران
فيها و بالتالي تمنعهم من اجلاء المصابين
وانتشال الجثامين من تلك المناطق التي
تتعرض الى استهداف مباشر منطقه الصناعه
تعرضت الى اطلاق نار وايضا اطلاق من الق
اطلاق قذائف من الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه المتواجده في محيطها ايضا
مستشفى الامل ومركز الامل التابع للهلال
الاحمر تعرض ايضا الى اطلاق نار بالاضافه
الى ان المسيرات ما زالت تحلق في سماء تلك
المناطق وفي سماء تلك الاحياء وتطلق
النيران على المواطنين الذين يحاولون
الخروج والهروب من حمم القصف الاسرائيلي
وهذه القذائف التي تسقط عليهم تسقط على
منازلهم تقصفهم الاليات في شققهم السكنيه
وهذه الطائرات المسيره تدخل الى داخل
المنازل والى الشقق السكنيه وتطلق النيران
على المواطنين وهناك عدد من الاصابات ما
زالت داخل هذه المنازل ويسعى السكان الى
نقلها الى المستشفى لكنهم محاصرون من قبل
الدبابات والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
القصف المدفعي ايضا مستمر ومتواصل على حي
الكتيبه كذلك في مدينه خانيونس في منطقه
وسط مدينه خانيونس وايضا على حي الامل
وكما قلنا في محيط مستشفى ناصر وكذلك في
محيط مركز التدريب التابع لوكاله غوث
وتشغيل اللاجئين الانرو ومن استطاع الخروج
من مدينه خانيونس باتجاه مدينه رفح هو
الان يواجه حواجز عسكريه اسرائيليه نصبها
الجيش الاسرائيلي على المفترقات الاساسيه
وبالتحديد عند منطقه مستشفى الخير ومنطقه
جامعه الاقصى هناك يتواجد الجيش
الاسرائيلي بكثافه نصب حاجزا عسكريا
اسرائيليا وكل من يحاول الخروج من مدينه
خان يونس يجب عليه ان يمر من هذا الحاجز
ويطلق النار على الناس الذين يحاولون
الدخول من طرق التفافه من شارع خمسه وشارع
القسام وبالتالي يطلق عليهم النار وهناك
عدد من الشهداء والاصابات ما زالت متواجده
على الارض في تلك المناطق وبالتالي من
يريد الخروج من خان يونس يجب عليه المرور
من امام بوابه الجيش الاسرائيلي او من
حاجزه سم اذا سمحت لي فقط اريد ان استوضح
نقطه كنت تتحدث عن عدد الشهداء الذين
وصلوا الى مستشفى الناصر في خان يوز اليوم
هل هي حصيله اليوم فقط ام اعداد تعود
لهجمات وغارات سابقه
الع هي حصيله 24 ساعه من عمليات القصف
الاسرائيلي المستمر والمتواصل على مدينه
خانيونس ما وصلهم 28 شهيدا وعشرات من
الاصابات ومن بين هؤلاء الشهداء من لم
تستطع سياره الاسعاف الوصول اليه واجلاء
الى مدينه خان يونس الى مستشفى ناصر الذي
لا يبعد سوى مئات الامتار عنهم وبالتالي
قاموا باجلاء وانتشاله الى مستشفى ابو
يوسف النجار في رفح وعدد من الاصابات حتى
ليلى انهم لا يستطيعون يذهبون من مستشفى
ناصر الى هذه الاصابات ويضطرون الى الخروج
من خانيونس لاجلاء المصابين الى مستشفيات
اخرى خاصه المصابين في المناطق الغربيه
والاطراف وبالتالي حتى الوصول الى مستشفى
ناصر الذي لا يبعد سوى مئات الامتار الى
من حي الامل او من منطقه الكتيبه او من حي
الشيخ ناصر او حتى من منطقه البطن السمين
سيارات الاسعاف في كثير من الاحيان لا
تستطيع الوصول اليهم ومن تستطيع الوصول
اليه احيانا لا تستطيع العوده الى مستشفى
ناصر ومن تستطيع العوده به الى مستشفى
ناصر هو عدد قليل جدا من هذه الاصابات
وهؤلاء الشهداء الذين يسقطون يوميا وما
كما قلت هناك بعض من الشهداء ما زالوا
ملقون على الارض ولا تستطيع سيارات
الاسعاف الوصول اليهم بفعل استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك مشهد ايضا
الصوره مؤلمه مهما قلنا ومهما اضفنا طبعا
يزداد حجم القسوه في المشهد اشكرك هشام زق
شكرا